cuomo's
[Music]
starring andrew
and chris
cool
yes
stelter's excuses are not so hot as
chris cuomo heads for the yacht
fox news caught up with chris cuomo at a
hampton's dock before he had a chance to
remove his shirt to show off his pecs
like his medium-sized polo you know he
shrunk it on purpose his lips were tight
have you spoken to your brother today
sir
of course are you continuing to advise
him
do you think that's an ethical conflict
think you got a job to do and i'm
letting you do it is your brother coming
to east hampton
yes if you wait here he'll be here in
five minutes
see
that's funny
yeah that's funny i could put that in my
monologue
at least he's finally learned to control
his temper right
he did not think my name was alfredo
don't be a liar
throw you down these stairs
wow he's changed which leads us to
someone who'd never lose his composure
unless it's around a box of krispy
kremes
yeah brian stelter
the perfect company man
are you applauding him or the joke uh he
defended cnn's handling of the cuomo
crisis on colbert new york times is
reporting that that's true chris was
helping his brother what's has that
created any conflict over at cnn behind
closed doors are people mad at him or is
he is he in trouble some people are mad
at him i also have a source that says
chris was on the phone with this brother
this week is your source chris
he is not he is not
you got to have boundaries he got to
draw a line why he doesn't uh i think he
does actually really i think chris does
i don't know about the governor well at
least uh stelter wore pants this time
he babbled saying there's nothing in the
journalist
journalism ethics book on how to deal
with this situation i guess it doesn't
have a section ah duh either although
it's nice to hear someone mention
boundaries when talking about the cuomos
and over at msnbc leave it to chuck todd
to plot cuomo's comeback his career was
either permanently over or
almost permanently over and he chose the
path of almost permanently over i expect
in my lifetime
andrew cuomo to probably run for office
again
chuck's only got five years to live
but the body's not even cold yet chuck
meanwhile tucker carlson proposed an
interesting theory about the new york ag
earlier this year she said that a.g you
thought it meant attorney general no
actually she said it stands for aspiring
governor which she is so there are
reasons to question laetitia james's
motives to put it mildly
so like my phone number at a truck stop
bathroom
the writing was on the wall for the
governor by the way when you do call
that number specify route and location
i've pretty much peppered the eastern
seaboard and i'm not going to drive
around forever
killed a whole weekend matt um
now i'm scared to die
tucker tucker has echoed what i've heard
a lot which is that yeah cuomo is a
creep
but wait do you see what's coming in i
mean you could get bill de blasio as
governor you could get leticia james i
mean is it better to have like a a less
crazy creep
than a non-creep who's a hardcore
leftist i don't know i'm having trouble
with the logic i'm glad he's gone yeah
say that but i do think
there's a special place at cnn for every
failed new york politician they have
given several shows yes i could see a
rebound of the man's career for sure
yeah and i think the thing more than
anything else that's really gross is to
see brian stelter say
who his sources are not yeah by the way
anonymous means you're not talking about
your sources you don't say well keep
coming with names
you're getting warmer you know it
doesn't work that way yeah you know it
was him it was cuomo cat could it could
there be an opportunity for the brothers
to have their own show
right right and because i mean yeah very
popular among the media when that
happened a boat show a boat show yeah
people are missing
a very important part of this story
which is that the the name of chris
cuomo's boat is heart strong like okay
buddy who names about that it's like a
movie about a high school football team
uh he's not the guy that he thinks he is
and it also
it blows the whole uh planned vacation
thing out of the water because who who
is there who makes millions of dollars a
year
and plans a vacation and just stays home
yeah nobody that's well you actually but
when your home is the hamptons
yeah i wouldn't know about that
she laughed
joe uh what do you make of this is this
story ongoing or is it about to flame
out no there's a lot to this first of
all uh for chris cuomo if your
nickname's fredo don't be going on any
boats
[Applause]
he's chilling the hampton his brother's
in the hampton inn by himself
have to
harass himself out of loneliness
here's the problem i had i greg you know
i get all my political predictions from
from cnn and from celebrities right of
course and i i miscalculated they told
me in 2020 that andrew cuomo was going
to be the next president of the united
states and i i wasted i spent all my
money making these bumper stickers
cuomo avenatti
2024 and i i can't i'm trying to unload
these
so
what i did i think these might might
move i had them edit them at the print
shop
once with the have the handcuffs on
that's like a really good editorial
cartoon it's really good just that yeah
are we allowed to bring props i didn't
know this i am
and you know what i think i should learn
my lesson from last time from these uh
weiner spitzer 2012.
he's been he's been carrying that one
around for eight years i have i've had
it in my backpack yes
it's got a yogurt stain on it
[Laughter]
where's the swoosh sign the nike sign
for avenatti you know
i asked the
[Laughter]
what should happen to chris cuomo
wow that's a great question why thank
you that's why i'm sitting here
uh well i don't i don't want to make any
judgment on any fellow peer well
journalist didn't he used to work here
as well yes he did did you know him back
then we were roommates it was really fun
you know the thing is we couldn't find a
place to live so we dressed up as women
and stayed at a woman's college
yes who was a star cheerleader back then
yeah yes yeah no but i love the did you
watch the resignation yes so i just
loved how the chirons were so behind and
they were just it was five minutes
behind before they said cuomo resigns
and i think everybody was just checking
with each other saying did he really say
that yeah that i just thought wow yeah i
guess we're just all double checking at
the same time yeah that was crazy cat
do you see what do you feel about chuck
todd saying that there's there could be
a con come back
i want to know what would possibly lead
to that yes
based on what evidence because it's you
know he resigned uh because this was all
really bad and he's a bad guy but
there's still all these other things
that he did even beside them the nursing
home and you avoid the nursing home the
uh priority testing for family and
friends the sorry i lose track he's
doing so many horrible things uh the
book the miss using the funds for the
book it's like and what a weird hill to
die on yeah why like why is ch why why
chuck did he get the tests maybe he got
the test yeah there you go there you go
but it it it is true it's like but you
know what he could still run again as
governor or he could run for mayor of
new york which would i would still take
him over de blasio
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else